hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game from the 1969 World Chess
Championship match
this was game 19 between Challenger
Boris baskey on the wide end
and he's up against the champ tigrin
Petrosian iron tigran as he was known
for his incredible defensive playing
style and his ability to withstand some
serious pressure by his opponents well
he was certainly under
a lot of it in this game and it comes
out of an open Sicilian nidorf
Bishop G5
black connects the knights prepared to
Simply recapture with the piece
Bishop C4 and in this game Queen A5 is
played more common nowadays is on this
move 7 for black to play Queen B6
where she puts pressure on both pawn and
Knight
the reaction here is to defend B2
what is one of the benefits
of having this pressure on D4
well it places a restriction on the
White Queen
who may in some cases prefer to
develop to E2 when she does make a move
she might want to go to E2
where she would be supporting an
eventual E5 Pawn advance to bother a
knight
okay white wouldn't have the E2 Square
available with the queen on B6
if for example on move 7 black first
played E6
you could see now the queen can freely
go to E2 no responsibility and if black
plays Queen B6 one move later it is not
an inconvenience at all for white who's
now one move out from Queen side
castling and there you go
talk about a convenient move you just
happen to be defending these two threats
okay
Queen A5 is played in this game now for
many moves in this game there may be the
Temptation playing as black to launch
the B Pawn and what I'd like to say
about this Advance is if you're playing
this move as black while the D5 square
is not yet under here control
in other words while E6 is not yet in
you're probably asking for a problem
I'm going to highlight one extreme line
that shows a really a really big problem
okay
if B5 right now there's Bishop D5
and if you move the Rook you're going to
get hit with the fork you may think
that's bad but it could be even worse
Knight takes Bishop Knight takes Knight
this is considered best white is still
for Choice here
it's a strong Knight on this Square
you could see many players in this
position right here playing as black go
with the move H6
saying this guy's irritating I don't
like being in a pin go away well guess
what this guy's not going away in fact
White's moving forward and your Queen Is
Dead
okay where do you go with the queen here
you're getting hit with B4 soon a knight
drops in here you have to sacrifice the
queen otherwise it's me
okay also if you take the Knight
you just lost in 12 moves
all right careful about playing B5 while
D5 is not yet under your control
in this game Queen A5 carries with it
some threats course the bishop and the
pawn are now Under Fire now that the
Knight is pinned it's not defending E4
convenient defense Queen D2
H6 Chop Chop Queen side castles
E6 okay this is where we can now start
to look a little bit more closely as
black at the B5 move now that D5 is
under control by a pawn
this does have White's attention for
sure on move 11 we have Rook H to E1
now
white is going first with piece play
rather than Pawn play
if you're gonna make a pawn Advance as
white in this position
the one move you probably go with is F4
you create that pawn Duo and nearby
there's ideas of either Pawn push E5 F5
both have their points both create
tension both are a step away from
creating more open lines for
the better developed side which is white
however
going with F4 right now
could be a bit of a problem for white
B5 Bishop B3 B4 for instance
where would you be going with the Knight
you go to the edge
you're getting hit with Bishop D Bishop
to D7 if you go backwards you just
dropped your E Pawn
what is the difference in other words
between F4 and Rook H to E1 on this move
11 well let's see
after Rook H to E1 in the game it's
Bishop to E7
what if black tries B5 right now with
the Rook on
E1 instead of the Pawn on F4
Bishop B3 B4 this Knight isn't going
left he's not going backwards he's going
forwards
this is not just a defensive move to
watch over this Pawn it's setting up
an eventual Knight D5 move it's
anticipating the B Pawn running forward
like this the Knight now has a great
Square
this is a fantastic position
for White Knight captured Bishop takes
what are you doing here we've seen this
before a rook move the knight's gonna be
landing a fork
one way or the other Knight takes Bishop
Pawn takes discover check and we could
see all the tactics are going to be
working out for white
Bishop blocks you could take land a fork
King has to go here the attack continues
Queen's hit Queen F4
a ton of ideas here look at the backward
development for black this is a winning
position for white my point big
difference between these two moves
have to watch out for Knight to D5 now
that the Rook is on E1 black respects
that obviously with this next move
Bishop E7 let me at least get to a point
where I'm only one move away from
getting castled
okay from here F4 only now
castles for black
some tucking in type of moves the bishop
to B3 I should also mention now that
this guy is on E7 the B5 moves can now
be hit
with Knight C6 and there's that fork so
okay Bishop B3 some regrouping for black
with Rook E8
like King tucked away
bishop f8 and where do we go from here
so I didn't mention this at the start
okay we're 14 moves in this game's over
by move 24. so what does white do now to
cause trouble and break team black in
just a 10 more moves well
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video
try and guess what White's next move is
okay
here we go in the game
a dash of Dynamics some Gambit play
he says go ahead take my G Pawn it's a
small investment
and I'm going to be able to function on
the G file
that's exactly what happens this Knight
ends up taking the pun I should note
if in this position you were thinking
about E5 that's another way to go
certainly appealing it's forceful
okay but his decision is to Simply sit
spassky's decision here is to sit with
the pawn Duo and look at this guy right
here I think this is maybe one of the
main
differences about the position we have
an instance of what opposite sides
castles and who has the safer King well
all these guys are right next to the
king and all of these guys are not this
guy here being on H6 sticking out like a
sore thumb it is providing white a hook
and there's a big problem right around
the corner with G5
so if you're not taking this you're
gonna get hit with G5 it's going to be
broken down one way or the other
Knight takes Pawn follows Queen G2
Knight F6
it may be tempting here
is white to play F5 because this
increases the pressure on E6 it creates
some open lines it tries to make this
Pawn Flinch so you have access to the D5
Square however
you in a way let black off the hook if
you go with that five in this position
because
we get some trades in and this is this
would be helping black to get these
exchanges and one pair of Rooks comes
off he's not so quick to allow Rook
exchanges he's still keeping two Rooks
on board so there's gonna be a shift now
now that there's this half open G file
there's going to be a shift towards the
king side of the board we have Rook e to
G1 and soon Rook D to F1 and the Rooks
are working in parallel on the king's
side
okay from here Bishop D7
F5 now
once this guy is off of the e-file
King gets out of two pins with King to
h8 however indirect there is one of
these guys was pinned along the diagonal
and the g Pawn was pinned as well
from here Rook D to F1
Queen goes back did you see the threat
here by the way with this last move
white is now ready to capture here and
then capture on F6 for instance let's go
with our favorite example move B5 okay
that's a big problem because of chop and
then there you go
Pawn takes Rook checkmate
so Queen going back home defends against
this idea defends F6
F takes E6 F takes E6 and now how to
continue only four moves out before
resignation
what does spassky come up with next if
you'd like to go ahead pause the video
see if you can spot his 21st move
okay
he comes up with the best move and it is
E5 now this isn't the only path forward
um
if you didn't come up with E5
um how could you maybe have
come up with E5
you know in these positions you could do
a scan what pieces are
performing uh you know are functioning
well we have the Queen the Rooks the
Knight and the bishop are in contact
with black side of the board
this Knight could do a little bit better
he's really not carrying his full weight
E5 opens up the E4 Square for the Knight
I should also mention
that trying to maneuver this night like
this and then here is also a very
effective plan but something that will
activate this Knight is called for in
this position
E5 on board very forceful giving
direction here the Knight is under Fire
Pawn takes Pawn
94.
both of these Knights are poison
here's the simplest one in this game
Knight H5 is played if this Knight is
captured it's a mate in two
Rook takes Bishop the key defender of G7
and then mate on G7
okay what would happen if this Knight is
captured what we're taking here
and the queen can't recapture and we
know what happens if the pawn captures
so these guys in the center poison
Knight H5
is now met with Queen G6
and in the game this Knight is captured
what would happen though if this Knight
goes into F4
no time to react to threats
all of this Force has been built up
you invest some material you address the
threat by giving up the Rook for night
and then focus on this G5 Square it's
not the most obvious move at first
glance at least but
this is the star move
in this position Knight to F3 and soon
enough a white knight will be
established on G5 and there's no good
way to defend
Queen H7 mate that's what the Knight on
G5 will be supporting
we could look at one sample line from
here such as Bishop C6
it actually turns out to be important
which Knight you go into G5 with here
if you go in with this one first there's
Bishop takes Knight and that's defending
the main threat
okay
it's this Knight here and basically
black will now have to give up the queen
for the night
to stop the mate and this is a winning
attack
still have ideas to maybe take here to
give a check go there winning position
for White Knight F4
instant capture
okay in this game Pawn takes Knight and
we're just one move out
final move of this game
Knight G5
black resigns and just like that what is
uh what options does black have there
are two serious threats
Checkmate and also the threat to win the
queen
how are you stopping that
you would have to take the Knight
and if you take the Knight you're gonna
lose this Knight with check now there's
this half open
H file
give check
give check on F7 and in chess there's
back rank mates and also side file mates
and that's right around the corner now
how do you defend it
this you simply take the pawn and it's
back on with Rook H3
and you may try to be clever with this
move and say aha I got that covered well
this guy's a not uh The Bishop's eyes on
V3 are now opened and that's me
and that's made even so there's simply
no defense after this last move
Knight to G5 black simply resigns so how
easily
it can crumble out of this position it
seemed very solid what black was doing
early on but that
small bit of Dynamics thrown into the
position there with G4 Knight takes G4
and open file King position
became a big issue
this guy over here on B1
perfect no Pawn advances no great danger
to the white king at all
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below I hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
foreign